foreign
welcome everybody
we'll be starting as you can see in
under three minutes
and it says 8 30 a.m because I am in
California
here with William Bailey
will be
helping us go through this uh
program today and
be over here on the East Coast
that's right almost lunchtime
yeah
we're joining you from the U.S
of course the program is through triple
it Bangalore and simplylearn is
headquartered in Bangalore so
we expect most of our audiences here
from India and
that's what we're seeing Chennai draw
ing
under Pradesh
and y'all
look on there is this live
yes Mr Singh this is live
or is it
yeah
people of a certain generation in the
United States used to see an ad that is
it live or is it Memorex
New York
Maybe
Tsar
indoor
kurukshetra
Mumbai
I know people from Ohio
that have operations in India and have
done the tours through India
that's not uncommon go
ahead
New Delhi
hotline V her state
oh yeah
all over India
and of course as we mentioned
someone joining from New York I am from
Northern California I'm joining from the
San Francisco Bay Area
church and Bill is training from the
East Coast
and we'll be starting in
five seconds
okay
and we can
oops
come on
apologies here
but it's a pleasant clock
yeah exactly
it's reminding me to
bring up our presentation here
great
so welcome everyone to our uh webinar
we're going to explore careers in cyber
security with the advanced executive
program in cyber security from triple it
Bangalore delivered through simply learn
one of our Premier instructors here uh
William Bailey who is an expert in cyber
security and we'll
have him introduce himself in a moment
but first i'm going to
um
tell you what we're going to be doing
today we'll be talking about the career
field of cyber security we'll discuss
what this program offers and how it gets
you job ready and then I'll go through
the enrollment steps including a bonus
offer which is our gift to you for being
here today
we're back
ah
getting ahead of myself here all right
so put your questions in the Q a
function in
um
zoom and we will get to those when we
get to the Q a
and I'm going to start with a poll
of our audience here so if you at all
let us know how many years of experience
you have and you should see the pull
widget on your screen right now
are you currently studying for your
degree or are you in the workforce
and I'm just going to leave this open
for about another 10 seconds
go ahead and put your answers in the in
the widget here and I'll close in five
four three
two one
in the poll
and sixty percent of our audience are
folks who are still at University or or
saying
and the rest of you are in the workforce
so we'll share with you how this program
works into whom it's targeted
and as I mentioned
here today with
William Bailey
and
um
Bill why don't you introduce yourself
and uh give folks an idea of your
background
sure sure happy to
um pleasure to be here today
um we've had a few of these events we've
talked about the different programs uh I
have actually been training I surprised
someone that I've been training for
simply learn we passed the 10-year Mark
and I think we hit 11.
over 10 years though I know that uh I've
been you know I say information security
over 20 years I it's it gets hard to
lose count you know I came up through
sort of the you know the the technical
ranks if you will the Hands-On technical
people and uh along the way realize this
thing about antivirus and security
concerns and so it sort of morphed into
that hey let's go down this road of you
know we didn't even call it cyber
security then but it became it became
cyber security it also touches on
privacy and risk
uh and uh I've been involved with the
local chapters of isaka uh the
Philadelphia area New Jersey area you
know uh Issa is another organization
that I've been a board member of for
many years
um and you know as far as experience you
know what does he do other than teach
classes
um yeah I I've
you know I I've worked for insurance
firm multinational Insurance firm for
years I developed a security revamped
and and led the security program for
credit union for a few years uh did a
lot of time Consulting uh which is then
you get that experiences you know it's
it's Financial Services it's Healthcare
it's retail it's your utility it's uh
your marketing your manufacturing you
name it the US government
um Consulting
and you could just get to see everything
all over the place and no matter where
you are you need cyber security so yeah
and that's that's kind of the theme of
today's uh presentation because we're
going to be talking about you know the
careers in cyber security and and
why it is such a vital and growing field
you know it's
something that
kind of touches everyone's lives even
more so since the pandemic because
people who were reluctant to use
mobile applications or
online banking or things like that kind
of got forced into it didn't they
uh you're on mute again Bill sorry
well you know that that's always good at
meetings where you're like you don't say
something you don't want to say right
um
uh you know three years ago covid-19 hit
and that was just crazy
um
everybody got sent home
and uh it's you know what's funny is
that you know the the cisos the cios
they say they haven't fully mitigated
their the new cyber security risks
because usually it is something that's
going ongoing and then of course you
know covid-19 hit and it just basically
stop everything you're doing
and now do this
yeah and there was a quote from a
webinar that I went to about two months
after the pandemic started uh executive
and whose name I'd
haven't been able to to trap back down
but an executive from a venture capital
firm who said if they had told us that
we would have to move everyone to work
from home we would have said great that
will take six months and we'll need 10
million dollars in budget when it
happened it happened within three days
with zero budget and the corollary to
that is it also happened with almost no
consideration of the cyber security risk
for that
that's uh you know the world we live in
today
well yeah there wasn't very allocated
budget uh because it was a crisis a lot
of vendors were actually pitching their
Solutions as a we're going to give you
the solution for two weeks a month uh
you know uh two months I think it was
what I was seeing was they they were
saying oh you don't have if you don't
have a solution for XYZ in place we'll
get you on board real fast in two months
um which was also really scary because
if you think about it now it's very hard
to pull yourself away from that provider
once you've hitched Your Wagon you know
it's like okay you were able to get up
and running
um in that emergency state but now you
know what does that look like going
forward and did you introduce any new
cyber security risks
you know and of course you know March
19th of 2020
um was sort of the big shutdown day for
a lot of organizations the the close the
closing of the doors yeah
um and I was actually I was supposed to
be actually in China back then
yeah well
possibly luckily because you might still
be there but um the the other thing
that's interesting from this uh this
particular slide is the 31 of the
executives who were
surveyed said that cyber criminals are a
bigger threat than nation-state actors
we always worry about well what if uh
terrorists or some hostile Nation
affects our infrastructure that type of
thing but that's not what really most of
us live with day-to-day because we live
under cyber security threat that's more
immediate
some ways you know more pernicious right
oh yeah the well the Cyber criminals can
be more
that are organized uh to be quite blunt
uh there this is an organized effort
because there's money there right uh
there is money to be made uh being a
cyber criminal uh I've actually seen the
videos where the Cyber criminals will
run a call center to provide customer
service for you uh so your nation states
uh they're gonna call attention to you
when there's some sort of a serious
reason for them to to attack you
um you know like you know a lot of the
retailers in the US that they're
probably not never going to see a nation
state uh Financial Services maybe
um because it could be considered cyber
warfare but the Cyber criminals it cuts
across the board to everybody and
because everybody
will pay everybody has systems and so it
does and it just you don't even have to
have a political motivation you could
just say I want money
yep it's uh hold on a second I'm
going to deal with something really
quick here in the
it's always fun sometimes we get that uh
the chat bot that just goes on and on
yeah
um so while you're cleaning that um
I know we've got questions we'll ask
we'll answer questions at the end right
um you know if you're doing a
non-technical
if you're doing another job and you
can't attend each live session
um we talk about you have to you have to
attend a certain number of sessions
um and we hope that you can actually
find a way to do that in person uh when
I say in person of course that means
life you know synchronously
um the recordings are always available
and so you know we'll try to work with
you there and if you say well there's an
overlap
between a live session uh versus you
know a work commitment
um hopefully you know if you can attend
most of the session and then catch up on
on what you missed you know there may be
some flexibility there it just depends
how wide that that that word they say in
business it depends
all right so let's go on hamsters yeah
no more hamsters
the growth of the cyber security Market
is uh
I mean it's phenomenal
the growth it's a it's bigger than some
State economies at almost 200 billion
dollars this year but
it's going to be close to 300 billion or
over 300 billion by the end of the
decade compound growth rate is uh
projected at 11 so
so a hugely growing field that reflects
the the fact that you know every point
of attack
can be a mobile phone can be the
computers in your
vehicles or other
Internet of Things devices so this is a
hugely growing field isn't it
oh it's
it is growing I'm because every every
time we see another attack the attacks
are just getting larger
um and and every time the attack occurs
the attackers get more emboldened and so
you know we've we've gone from things
that were just a curiosity decades ago
with the Morris internet worm oh let's
see what I can do oh this is neat and
there was no necessary no harm in what
they were doing you know now cyber
security is just going to permeate and
of course you know the accessory
acceleration to mobile cloud and
Internet of Things
uh it's the cyber security is just going
to continue growing and and of course
then there's also legislation which
um you know and different parts of the
country different parts of the world
have different laws
but then what happens is we're
globalized yeah and so like I said I
know folks that you know they could be
us-based uh but they're they they have
operations in India uh they have
operations in Europe and so now if
Europe has a cyber security law they
still have to follow it so even if you
say oh I'm an Indian I don't have to
follow this law well it depends do you
do business with another entity
uh that does and if so now you're going
to have to have those cyber security
controls if you want to have earn that
business from that other organization
by the way uh you know somebody who
cited a more another statistic he saw
that said the revenue growth is actually
closer to 18 a year so
that's pretty amazing
um and
move on
to commensurate with that salary for
people in this field
the
got a pretty high cap I mean
the these are numbers from Glassdoor
India
and
the average person working as a cyber
security engineer in India is making
seven lock per year
um
if you move up into management over time
with additional skills and additional
training then you move into a career
field where the average salary is 17
luck
and those are pretty substantial
salary potentials especially when you
look at the upper limits where you can
go as your experience increases
so this is a it's kind of parallel to
what happens in the United States isn't
it
uh you're still on mute
I do yeah I there's a lot of folks will
say oh I see the the starting salary and
every sophomore will have someone to say
well do I have to take a pay cut to get
into cyber security I go well maybe
temporarily you know because if you've
done say 10 years at a firm you've
gotten uh sitting already you know time
basically your yearly bonuses yearly uh
raises and salary uh and sometimes you
may take a dip uh if you're going into
cyber security but what happens is you
know it's you know you you end up within
a year or two you've you've totally buy
you've you've leapfrogged over what you
would have made
um because of the cyber security uh
salaries especially uh if you have you
know you have this education behind you
as opposed to you know when I was
starting out we just we were in the you
know sitting in our apartments in our
basements and and cobbling together
things because cyber security was still
you know up and coming uh now yeah it's
you know employers are also looking for
that and so that's where that salary
bump happens because they'll say oh you
know you've you know you've completed
this program and so now we recognize
that that program is a well-rounded set
not just you've been near a computer for
a period of time and so the yeah the
salary bumps do definitely occur
absolutely
yeah
so
these are again looking at Glassdoor
and you look at uh
companies that are listed as
currently
um
hiring these are some of the top names
that come up in the listings Tata of
course
um
woodpro but also Global consultancies
like you you Ernst young UI Deloitte
Accenture PWC
um
these
kinds of companies are hiring because
they're being hired by other companies
to help secure their
cyber security environments correct
oh absolutely I I know organizations
that are using Tata ey we Pro Deloitte
Accenture PWC uh and there's a few there
are others out there that uh uh that
definitely
um have operations uh around the world
and so you're gonna find them hiring all
around the world uh I'm trying to think
uh oh gosh what is uh rkl I think was
one of them
um and there's a few other
um audit and cyber security consulting
firms that they're around the world and
so these are like the big six names that
you're gonna see all the time and
there's just a whole plethora of other
organizations yeah I mean these are just
like the first six names I picked off
but uh if you go on to
any of the job sites you'll find that
the number of cyber security jobs
is plentiful
and they fall into these kinds of
categories I mean you can engineer it
can be manager analyst uh you can
specialize in in particular areas what
are some of these how do some of these
roles differ from one another
good question oh and someone said
capgemini you know so many firms out
there yeah yeah
definitely a big one
um yeah the roles you see here says
someone earlier in the chat um also said
that they were a hacker right you know
in hacker uh read you'd be your red team
or you could be defending and you'd be
on the blue team
uh and the you know the skills you can
get you could be a developer you could
be an analyst
um you know you could be an analyst uh
security analyst malware analyst Cloud
security analysts you know you could be
a threat Hunter
um and that's right we all start out
um it's somewhere right and a lot of
times you end up becoming a con I ended
up becoming a consultant where really
I'm across the board and sometimes I
have to do a little bit of multiple
roles
uh I'm gonna have to you know because
it's like oh I can't just I can't just
do this one thing because what does a
client want
yeah and so the interesting thing is
that you can start in in with a general
background move into a specific area of
concentration or stay General and move
up into management or Consulting and you
have lots of different career paths
available to you
um you need however to have a pretty
well-round background
I mean
this a fair
roster of the kinds of skills you need
that's a fair yeah this is you know
we're looking at this list here
um and I see some folks talking about
Hands-On skills yes um and we're gonna
we talk about that we have the lab
environment we'll talk about
um but yeah yeah I have to understand
the infrastructure and that changes
obviously over the last decade we've
seen Cloud Technologies totally change
and our applications are are 90 of them
at this point are really mobile based uh
or web-based uh we're not seeing a lot
of you know traditional client server
but there's still some Legacy stuff
that's out there that still needs
support uh you know and of course
everything is encrypted or decrypted
there's this need for uh cryptographic
methods to keep information secure and
also accurate
um you know malware continues to be
something that we see and just the
analysis and handling I mean that's one
of the things that's not specifically
called out here is incident response you
know uh you know security operations
center yeah stock analyst yeah that
might be a role and those change right
because you sit there go well I know
Microsoft Windows NT and no that doesn't
work anymore you have to keep up to date
the store's like no I'm like yeah
exactly right we're not we're long past
the days of NT and some of the other
Legacy systems
yeah and
of course I I'm an A Relic because I
learned
initially how to program using punch
card decks in Fortran but that's a whole
different world back then we weren't so
worried about cyber security because
you actually literally had to deliver a
punch card deck to the computer before
you know to the computer Operation
Center before you could run a program
but
that uh that's not the world we live in
today and today you have to be aware of
these things
um what is the reason I'm going to ask
the audience members that you're all
here because you're interested in
potentially career in cyber security but
why haven't you taken a program of this
type so far what is it that you haven't
found
that you feel you need
oops
did I just mess up the poll
nope that's a postal gun
and I'll leave it open for another 10
seconds because you can answer multiple
answers to this question
and I will close the poll in five
four three
two
one hit that submit button
and
uh parallel to what was going on in the
chat you can see that half of the
audience responded that they are worried
they wouldn't get practical exposure
they wouldn't have
hands-on experience after a program like
this and then
um
40 said that there looking for a program
that has a comprehensive curriculum that
covers all of the skills that we just
talked about so
let's discuss how this program
helps you meet those needs
come on
there we are
Advanced executive program in cyber
security uh it comes from triple it
Bangalore
when they designed this program
um they'll talk more about the
institution in a bit but they designed
it to have the comprehensive curriculum
looking for because they work with a
number of companies in Industry they get
requests for specific skill sets people
who are being trained into different
areas so for cyber security they've been
logging the requests from their industry
partners and they came up with a
learning path that meets those needs it
includes integrated case studies and
Hands-On projects because as many of you
correctly pointed out you cannot learn
this just from watching or reading you
have to learn it by doing
and that's one of the cool things right
bill in terms of
having live instructors who will take
you through these exercises and having a
lab environment that's right on your
browser that you can
can do at your desktop or laptop
but you really have to you can't just
look through a series of PowerPoint
slides that
um doesn't get you enough it absolutely
doesn't
um and you can't just read you have to
have some sort of a test lab to work
with uh it because you have to get your
hands dirty and I used to say even when
I'm leaving a security program even if
my hands aren't on the keyboard every
single day I still need to know and part
of it so that I can vet out the vendors
that I'm going to hire so that I can vet
what they're trying to sell me and they
said they'll say oh I'm going to do a
vulnerability scan or a penetration test
well you know they they LED with the
penetration test they really only wanted
to do a vulnerability scan and you had
to know the skills in order to basically
to call them on it and ask them well
what tools are you going to use and then
they give you a list of tools you go
okay nope I know the list of tools
nothing in there we'll do a penetration
test so yeah it's that's part of that
that's why still having a test lab
um and you know it used to be that you
would set up machines you can't do that
now
um you could set up virtual machines you
can someone said can I download Cali
onto Windows 10. you could download
Virtual machines and
um but then of course you know the the
always one of my roles as an instructor
you know faculty member trainer is to to
take what's what's there and and and try
to make it easier to understand and also
to find you know the pitfalls that other
people have fallen in and and help
Learners through that uh to learn
through those areas where it could be
challenging
um and and to keep the momentum going
forward uh and also of course because
it's an organized course
um everyone you're you're staying on
track time once so it's not like the
three year I'm gonna go take this test
and it takes three years and you still
haven't passed the test
yeah
and that's an important aspect because
it's something that can be done
realistically this program is scheduled
for six months and it's a part-time
program it's ten hours a week and that's
by Design to be able to get you the
skills without interrupting your career
um so
how well does that work well you've done
many cohorts in our programs
um how
how well do people get trained within
that period of time if they apply
themselves
they apply themselves they are ready to
go at the end of it
um you're spending you know a few hours
of class time
every week and then you're you have a
little bit of homework
um but uh you know most of the batches
that are the cohorts that we've had
these cohorts have been uh in the
evening so it's something there you've
got a day job and then at night you can
take the course
um the the course sessions are recorded
So if you want to go back and replay it
if something urgent came up and you had
to step away for a few minutes you can
go back to it
um but but you're also not just
listening to a recording and so you can
actually correspond communicate back
with your instructor
uh live during the class uh and also in
between in the in between the classes so
you say something on a Saturday
it's not a class day but you can post a
message to the community forum and you
can get support uh on that kind of
question
um so you're not losing the whole week
yeah
that's important
um some of our cohorts are set up for
evening classes some are set up for
weekend classes you have the flexibility
to choose the you're able to
adapt your program to your particular
work schedule so the end of the process
you're going to get
certificates from
triple it Bangalore
but you're also going to get a
certificate for the virtual internship
that is part of that uh
program
from npci at the national payments
Corporation of India because the the
final part of this program is a virtual
internship there that allows you to
demonstrate your skills in a real
working environment so you've got
multiple projects that you've done along
the way you build a portfolio of those
got the virtual internship you get
master classes with experts instructors
from my triple it Bangalore as well as
from ncpci and you get a career assist
service from Simply learn which is
help you get placed into that first job
or to get you a better job
and let me mention the Institute triple
it lower
uh established 1998
and as it became that much more
important in the Indian economy and
Indian industry
a triple it Bangalore took the Forefront
of that
effort and research education Innovation
supporting entrepreneurship
and as I mentioned Partners a lot with
the corporate sector so that they keep a
very
good finger on the pulse of what the
needs of Industry are tailored their
programs so that they're training people
to fulfill those roles and triple it
Bangalore of course
it's a well-known and well-respected
Institution
to having that certificate is uh
something that people will notice
be eligible for the program you need a
bachelor's degree with 50 Cent 50 marks
or better
uh you need to have a minimum of one
year of work experience
but for those of you who are still
studying you'll want to come back to
this once you've been in the industry
for a year or if you are studying but
you already have the work experience
um you'll be able to join right after
you or earn your bachelor's degree the
rest of you working uh
qualified if got that one year of
experience in bachelor's degree you do
need to have basic understanding of
program Concepts so
the programming doesn't have to be your
main field or your main occupation but
you do not have to have some exposure to
that
and of course simply that offers courses
that can help refresh your skills in
that area
let's talk about the curriculum and how
the program prepares you
and we'll go into the learning
environment
um are you ready to do that uh Bill do
you want to do that after
let's see I could do the I could I could
show the curriculum and uh the virtual
classroom and I have a lab started up
um that I can do let's take us through
that
sure so let me
my share button here
oh okay yes I want to continue yes you
do it
yep
okay so all right so what I did I just
you know as far as to give you an idea
of what this uh program looks like
um
the uh
I was looking to see here where we're
going here is it sorry yep okay right so
usually what you would see this is a
similar program uh that um simply
learned has partnered with another
institution to offer a similar program
and you you work through these courses
here and you you'll notice it'll be like
100 percent because you've completed
these courses uh and if I say okay if I
want to go look at self-learning
in this particular course
the uh yeah so you know you can go back
um you can attend the live classes
and you can notice here that you can
listen to the recordings
if you've missed something or you want
to go back and review it you can always
do that uh to get these certificates you
get actually with the with this
particular program there are actually a
series of uh certificates that you would
go through and then at the end you get
one for the overall partner
uh but you know it's it's based on you
know did you attend the the program uh
you know there's some material in here
you know self um self-paced learning
that you could also watch as well so you
get so you're getting that experience
two different ways
uh now as far as the labs the practice
Labs here uh those actually
uh I lost but uh I have over here
starting up another one and basically
what you would be looking at here would
be you have a series of labs and and
right now it's taking a moment for this
to fire up
um the the lab but like this particular
course has Cali and windows 2016. uh so
you're
so you're attending classes and then
when you look at the course material
there'll be specific Hands-On activities
and the lab environment is right out
here uh which means you don't have to
support it uh and if you want to you
could just you could click the reset
button and it would just reset that
uh
so you have that ability to access
um I'm waiting for it to start up it's
going to take it a moment but what's the
greatest it'll it'll come up eventually
so the other what was the other thing I
was looking at here
um
and I have to move my mouse away
um or I could just exit out of the class
I'll just exit out of the class here
you'll notice that you have access to
the community Forum uh and what would
happen is for instance that cohort would
be specific uh to your group and so you
have a community Forum that's just your
group and you can post the questions and
queries in the community forum
uh as um as Stuart mentioned uh we have
other courses that you know in this
program there were some optional courses
that were available
uh this is the whole track that you
would go through and you know your
progress towards completing that
particular program
and on my screen just changed there live
uh because literally yes it is now
logging into that is Cali
and I did not have to actually install
Cali on my system
all right it is right there all right
um you know and I could I could go out
here and I could
you know launch browser I could launch a
whole set of applications in this
pre-configured environment
uh so this makes it easy to learn your
material because you're basically you're
going through the self-paced learning
you're going through the the live
classes and you have access to an actual
Kali Linux machine up in the cloud
um if something goes wrong you could
just have it reset or create a help
ticket and have it reset
um so there's a little bit of lag there
I uh apparently I you know it was
starting up I I was a little impatient
um but there we go you know we have this
Kali Linux that's up and running ready
to go and the labs
we'll walk you through what to do inside
the the you have directions for the labs
then you come into the lab environment
and you can complete your course
exercises
so it's all appeared together
and you don't have to download any of
this to your system it's
being accessed through your browser
it's the Virtual Lab environment in the
cloud
yep it's all up on the cloud and so yeah
it's very easy to go you know in the uh
when you're in one of these courses here
right I just click on this link and
you're going to see like over on the
left hand side you're just going to see
that practice lab you just click on that
and it will take you into that lab you
also see the fact that there's uh in
this course self learning modules and
live class modules uh typical of the
courses you have resources that you can
use that are uh pre-recorded videos or
ebooks or
PowerPoint presentations that will take
you through
um
some of the material you want to review
before your live class and you've got
your live class environment of course
where you start to we'll take you
through that material
and then you've got your practice labs
and other
forms of doing the Hands-On work and
finally as you can see the assessment
tab there
yeah oh yes thank you I forgot about
that you're actually you'll go into the
lab environment you'll complete and
exercise and like if I click on this
right well I already passed the project
okay
um so I had to find a project that I
didn't complete
um but basically basically here you see
the description down below you know in
this case what they were talking about
was here's the project use web goat uh
to test web vulnerability uh web
applications for vulnerabilities and
perform SQL injection attack and so
you'll go so they'll give you a scenario
and then you'll go and do that activity
and you'll upload the proof that you did
what was asked and someone you know it's
pass or fail
um you you and so what would happen is
someone would complete it
um and then it actually gets reviewed
um you get feedback back on that uh to
60 you know successfully clear that that
hurdle or that uh checkpoint if you will
it's basically a competency checkpoint
uh so it's not just you know you're not
just listening to videos you're not just
listening to an instructor you're not on
your own uh and and you're getting these
regular checkpoints
uh through the materials
excellent
okay so let's go back to
um and as you mentioned the community
um
you have the ability to start a thread
or join the thread for your particular
course that you're in particular group
that you're in batch and
pose questions to your peers your
instructors get that type of thing but
you also have 24 by 7 help support
uh correct yep yeah um and actually up
here yeah here's the community link
right here up in the upper right hand
corner
uh and up here is our help and so you
could do the help and
um there's some suggested tips already
here uh if you have questions about
certificates live classes your profile
the program self uh self-paced Learning
Materials Etc
um
and I don't know if it's using chat GPT
yet uh but there's a there's a live chat
with with someone there
um and so a lot of these are you know
it's a question about how do I access a
class
um I'm having technical issues you know
how do I unlock my certificate
um we have that chat bot for that uh or
not these people chat people it's a
combination because you a lot of what
you needed to get done you can get done
instantly through the chatbot but if if
it's something beyond the ability for
the AI chatbot to deal with we have Live
24x7 help desk so
you're able to move to a live person
and get that issue resolved so
and the community would be maybe I have
a question about uh how do I use the DD
command in Linux and you know and and so
that would be a form that you can use
that Community Forum to get those
questions answered so you're not waiting
the full week
um and we try to you know all these
sessions all the sessions that I'm part
of we try to keep them very Interactive
okay so
um I think I'll move back to our main
presentation if that's all right with
you yep
here we go
so as we saw in the uh
in the demo here that there's a specific
sequence that we go through in this
curriculum to take you in
through Enterprise information security
then to application and web security
ransomware malware analysis and then
ethical hacking and concentration
testing
um
and then the virtual internship so
this kind of takes you in a logical
sequence right bills
from from one layer to the next
but yeah everything builds from the
orientation session on up it's building
your skill set uh it's getting you know
the building blocks getting the
foundation ready and so by the time you
get to that virtual internship
um you're able to actually do the work
and a lot of times you you actually
could take some of these course end
projects that we just showed and maybe
that and that would go into a portfolio
when it comes time when you're looking
for work and uh still you're even though
I have years of experience I'll be asked
oh can you give me a sample of your
writing can you give me a sample of XYZ
report and and so that's one of the
other things you're getting out of this
as you're completing the work save that
off to the side because now that's part
of your portfolio that you know if
someone says can you give me a sample of
X you have it yep
um you also have the access to the
master classes you can train for your
ccsp exam and you can take classes on
security government governance I'm sorry
um
for a higher level view so
those are optional but they are no no
additional cost included in the program
so
you will use in the virtual Labs a
number of different tools you saw an
example for example
using Kali Linux and assignment that
required to use you to use web good in
particular
exercise you'll get these types of
things across the board
to these tools that see here and many
more that you'll be
using in specific assignments so that's
really the best way to to become
proficient at these
I'm Stuart I hate to interrupt you here
um I've looked I don't have the ability
to
export people from chat okay let me do
that
so I could talk to the tools briefly
here
um the tools and actually I think we
just showed you Cali
um in the lab which is really it's
almost like a Swiss army knife of tool
sets
um because it's a Linux distribution uh
you know you instead of just regular
Ubuntu it has all these hacking tools
ethical hacking tools that are
pre-loaded into it
um you know the others someone earlier
had mentioned uh parrot black Arch you
know Kali Linux is sort of the go-to
standard and then once you know how to
do things in Kali Linux then you could
take your your knowledge set and you
could then go work with another uh
distribution if you wanted to
um
the uh you know openvis and NASA's
vulnerability scanners uh that every
organization should be running
vulnerabilities scans into what they
have because it's all too often
somebody's just going rogue and setting
up a machine
um and they plug it in and it's running
but then no one knows what's on it no
one knows what vulnerabilities that
someone could someone could come in and
exploit uh to get access
okay
let's move on
so the virtual internship very important
because it allows you to Great
partnership within npci and it allows
you to demonstrate your skills in a real
working environment
and
that gives you
something that you'll be able to show
off not only because of the certificate
because of the portfolio of work that
you do as uh Bill explained having the
real world examples and having that
practical hands-on experience something
that everybody said was important to
them and this is a program that will do
that for you program also gives you uh
a kind of an envelope or a cocoon of
support you have a program manager who
interacts from the simpler learned side
with triple it Bangalore make sure that
we're delivering the program according
to their specifications you have a
manager that manages the success of all
the Learners who join at the same time
in the same cohort
you have
instructors of course who are helping
you get through each of the modules
and
then learning teams and peers among the
people that you are studying with and of
course the curriculum resources are
another part of that
let me take a look we have a couple of
you know just just going on
yeah you know I was going to say hackers
but you know they're really just
disruptors today
um the uh yeah it's basically the simply
learned community supports you
um you know instructors like myself uh
program manager the cohort manager
um and the curriculum is designed uh to
work you through and to get you the
right skills you need at the right time
as you're working your way through
um and your own learning teams and your
peers as you go through the program
okay
so you're not on your own
good
so
these are the people who you
report to in the program Professor
sritar versus professor
who are all
um
as I said with triple it Bangalore who
all contribute from their different
aspects into the cyber security
curriculum and the design of the program
for educational Effectiveness so these
are the people to whom we report that
simply learn and these are the people
who put their name and reputation behind
your certificate
let's talk a little bit about learner
outcomes these are some of the the
testimonials we'll see if you go to our
website and see the program page uh that
should Dr dorsami and Akash
um
it's notable that Akash was able to move
up in his career to a 40 salary hike
which is a pretty good
um
outcome from the program and then
Dr dursomi is talking about the
value of the instruction
way that it was structured so that he
was able to absorb the material well
even though he has his doctorate
found that this was a useful way to
upskill
this is a really great uh
I think assembly of testimonials but
we hope that we can add yours to the mix
in the future
have you had similar kinds of experience
with the people you've taught bill
whenever we go through these programs we
usually we see some people will come
into the program and they've got a skill
set already they've got some beginning
skills and sets but then we also see
people who have no
or very little experience and
you know by the time we get to the end
if you've if you put in the time if you
do all that work you do those confidence
competency checkpoints you do those you
know midi projects as you're going
through the program uh by the time you
get to the end of it you're able to do
everything that that program wanted you
to do absolutely uh you know the
comprehensive the curriculum itself is
designed so that you can get to that
steps
um and then of course you know you've
got your your learning your peers your
learning teams and your instructors to
try to help you work through that issue
you know and try to if you've got you
know sometimes there aren't bumps in the
road but that's okay you know
um because you don't necessarily want to
stay put either
right that would be the comfortable
option but it would mean you wouldn't be
doing what you want to do you know uh so
yeah you take that extra effort and yes
by the time people are done with the
program they can do everything that the
program was designed for them to do and
they can go out and get those roles and
you know either get a promotion and get
a promotion within their firm or
organization or go somewhere else right
you know uh salary range is uh vary but
I've never I've never heard anyone say
no I've I've gone backwards or it's it's
always been I'm glad I'm did that
exactly
um so we had a question about the job
placement services
simply learn offers job assist Services
which is not job placement uh it's a set
of services that'll help you find a job
it's for people who join the program
from India or have the right to work in
India because it's focused on jobs in
India and this is access to the IIM jobs
job portal for six months after you
complete the program at the premium
level but it also includes resume review
and rewrites so that you have a chance
to work with a writer who will take you
through a couple of rounds of uh
improving your resume so that
are adapted to
passing through the AI filters that
initially deal with resumes these days
and also remains attractive to the
humans who will eventually see that
resume
um and then one-on-one interview prep
where you get to work directly with
um
individual
interview preparers will take you
through the different kinds of
interviews you have to do
from phone screens to technical job
interviews looking at the kinds of
questions you'll be asked about your
cyber security skills and then how to
deal with the
cultural fit managerial level interviews
that look at your work ethic and other
aspects of your personality so those are
all different aspects these are all
invaluable ways that we can help you
find that next job
and again it's not job placement but it
is a set of services that you can access
as you need them for the six months
after you complete the program
and based on what we've told you today
are you interested
in
training this program
and go ahead and answer
is this program just for Indians this
program is designed for Learners in
India but it is open to people around
the world
to the pricing is in Indian rupees
uh class times are good set mainly for
an Indian audience but um again it is
open people across the globe
and uh in the poll here
80 of our audience said that they are
interested
this is where I'll share with it I'm
going to change over the chat because
we're going to be going to questions and
answers so we want you to direct your uh
chat to just uh Bill and me
uh
uh here we go
so we're going to be joining since
questions and answers momentarily after
I share with you the process for getting
enrolled
here we go enrollment steps
oops
the program fees are one lock fifty four
thousand nine hundred ninety nine uh you
can Emi finance that at
5275 per month that's
very low interest rate not quite zero
yet but um our bonus offer for attending
this is you can take 10 off of that or
fifteen thousand rupee discount for a
being here today that's our gift to you
our thank you for joining the next
cohort
join the cohort by doing
uh three simple steps the first step is
to submit to us an application at ask us
simplylearn.net
and um then we will review that we'll be
asking you for information about your
educational background
proof of your bachelor's degree uh we'll
be asking for proof of your work
experience
and do a simple assessment test of your
programming aptitude
and from that we'll offer you admission
if you qualify
and
I just put the uh
email into the chat
our next cohort starts with classes in
July so you'll want to get involved
quickly because next week is the welcome
session for that cohort
and we do have a limited number of
spaces
class sizes we have to limit the class
sizes to about or cohort sizes to about
25 to 30 people
correct bill
in order to make sure that you have
attention time you and your fellow
instructors
yeah that number's about right
um if it gets too long we can't have it
get too large because then we can't give
the attention if someone has a question
oh and and the people who understand the
material are being held back
um so you know the cohort you go
together right you you're learning
together
um and and so that's where that size is
like you just mentioned that's 25 to 30
Max because we want to make sure that
everyone can get through the material at
the pace not fall behind it is a team
this is you know like a sporting event
it's a team we're all going to get there
yeah absolutely and so we we recommend
that if this is of interest to you to do
it as soon as you can
um
and I'm going to ask that very question
from the audience
which is
how soon are you interested in doing
this are you looking at the July classes
or are you looking for the Denver
you know that some of you are still
studying for a degree so you won't be
eligible for the program for a little
bit but for those of you who are
uh What's the timing that's you have in
mind I'll close this in five
four three
two one
and
so about fifty percent of our audience
would like to do this either in July
August September time frame and so we
encourage you to email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net right away but we also
encourage everyone else to do that
because that way we can keep you in
touch and ask you about other needs you
may have
share with you the um
uh future cohorts and answer any
questions that you might still have
outstanding so
let me move on and go to the Q a this
point
we're going to stop sharing the screen
and
that way you'll be able to
talk to me and
Bill directly
okay so let me take a look at what we
have in terms of questions in the Q a
and then we'll take a look through the
chat to see if they're any there uh you
already addressed the question from who
asked
um
about what happens if you can't get to
every class live
how long is the program six months
how to get a job for cyber security and
again this is where the job assist
program comes in
how to download
Linux from Windows 10. so Bill you don't
really have to to download Kali Linux to
your machine to do this program
um unless you really want to correct
that is absolutely correct I mean you we
we talk about it that you know you can
do virtual machine you could put Kelly
Linux on your machine but the beauty of
the lab is that it's pre-setup
environment it's you know yes it took a
few minutes for it to load but once it
loads it's right there and it's ready to
go with all the activities all the tools
and so forth yeah and any Cloud
exercises that you do that the access to
the cloud services are included in the
course so
um benefits of the course of course
we've talked about that but the
benefits are that you're going to learn
a comprehensive set of cyber security
skills with hands-on experience and
expert instruction live so that makes it
very different from many other
Avenues of learning out there
uh we had a someone asking what to do
after
they complete their secondary school
before they go to university and get
into cyber security this particular
course does require that you have an
undergraduate degree
um you might contact us at ask us simple
one.net to find out what other types of
programs or courses we have that you can
take without
being at that level yet would you get a
certificate of this webinar we will send
out a certificate of attendance for this
webinar to people who are here for more
than 20 minutes today
um
and
sorry about the the various spammers I
got that as a question here
um
is there any age limit in cyber security
that's an interesting question bill is
there uh any age Beyond which you just
can't handle it
I
you know I think the only age limit is
set by the individual
um there are people who I know who have
worked their whole life and then they
basically went into a second career more
you know or basically they worked for an
employer they collect they got to the
point of collecting retirement and then
they said okay great now I'm going to
keep working for someone else
uh and so I it's there's really no age
limit you know and there's no lower
limit either
um you know and at that point earlier
you know yes
um the the program you do need to have
um some undergraduate uh college
experience or university experience
whatever
um because in University they'll teach
you how to write and and uh cyber
security we do have to learn how to
write reports
so that's one but there's no reason that
it needs to be in a cyber security
program it could just be part of your
University
yep
um
somebody asked if you could name drop
some of the organizations you've worked
for
are you allowed to do that
um I you know I think some of the best
things I've done like actually with
simple learned years ago I
um we I believe I taught a course
overseas for simply learn and literally
it was on an army base
um we've had some fun with
um NCIS not the TV show
um
um Visa uh has you know I'm trying to
think who else has been in that that I'm
like wow who who would have thought
about that right
um a lot of large institutions
um and you know I the other ones I can't
really name I always have to uh protect
the names right um you know because if I
say well XYZ company had a situation
where they had this breach
weakness no I can't do that because I
signed an NDA I'm not allowed to say
um well I won't put you on the spot any
longer um yeah someone uh Huda says
they're getting into a b-tech cyber
security and
uh is this
is a degree in cyber security uh the
good path this program of good path
you know or do they complement each
other
up you're muted yourself for some reason
the the latter answer because a lot of
times when you get a degree like a
college degree University degree
um like I said you have to take all
those general education which is yes you
need to know math yes you need to know
English and writing and and you need to
learn more about the world sometimes
because it helps you fit in with
industry a bit better because you have
an understanding
uh of the world and just sort of this
common base of knowledge now as far as
cyber security do you need a cyber
security specific University degree no
um you don't um and that's where the
certificate plus your University degree
then complement each other
because you you're focusing your efforts
you know this six month program is
probably going to be a lot less
expensive than a standard university
it's probably going to be a lot more
attainable than a university program and
faster than a four-year degree or a two
years master's degree exactly yes
um somebody who's pursuing the Google
Google cyber security professional
certificate
um
how
is that sufficient for them to qualify
for an entry-level job
uh you know I mean I
um I
I have to look in I have to look at that
a little bit more
um there one of the things I saw
recently and I
they supposedly that Google was going to
have this thing and it was going to be
free
and I remember I saw recently someone
said well it's not really free
it was like wait a minute I could sign
up for the program but I can't do
anything in the program unless I pay oh
um and that's one of the things
sometimes we have to be careful of
um you know the uh even AWS Amazon I'm
doing some of their tradings right now
and I'm talking with someone I'm saying
well I'm going to Avail myself of all
the stuff that's free before I sign up
for their their subscriptions that they
have uh you know no because Amazon you
know I'll take all the free stuff I can
but the free stuff's only going to get
you so far and I think that's what we're
gonna then the question is how far do
you get before the the pop-up window
comes up and says oh time to pay
um here you know the the cost of the
program you know what it is and and you
know that the curriculum
um the curriculum has already been
established where so you're not cherry
picking and that's the other if you're
trying to cherry pick horses sometimes
you may not it's harder to get that you
know cohesive unit uh that makes sense
um and and this cohort you're gonna go
together is one group it's all going to
be lined out the lab environment's
already there you know you're not going
to find the the miscellaneous up charges
along the way you paid for the lab
environment you pay for the course you
pay for the program it's all included
and the the placement assistance the you
know the the resume rewrites which oh
yes absolutely you want someone who's
written resumes to get you past that HR
Gateway and that's where this is all
inclusive
you know from from point A to point B
yeah plus the fact that
you'll have live instructors who are
taking you through the material rather
than just
just sitting there staring at the screen
and trying to figure it out on your own
so
some people learn that way but um
many people
do not and I've always for example been
one who
benefits from that live instruction
um
cyber security is cyber security
difficult to learn
um you know there's a saying
how do you eat an elephant yeah one bite
at a time fight at a time
yep that's that's the answer there yeah
you know you're not going to learn it
overnight
um and we're not going to learn it we're
not done either I mean I'm still
learning things all the time
um
the certificate is recognized worldwide
because triple it Bangalore has a
worldwide reputation does the course
include ccsp certification it does
include a uh an elective that will train
you and prepare you for ccsp
certification of course the the actual
exam is something that you have to take
from that body right
yeah so yeah the ccsp is an elective
that you could take the actual exam
voucher that you have to pay for
I'm just sit for the exam uh is not
included
um IC squared is the organization behind
the ccsp uh and uh they have you know
you have to sign up for the exam if you
reschedule the exam then there's a fee
for that
um once you pass the exam there's a fee
to renew it periodically
um so that's something you know I that's
ISC squared that's our own exam but the
ccsp curriculum uh it's a course that
you know to learn the material that's
one of the electives in this program
V shall ask if you can get a job abroad
from this type of certification and you
in the world we live in today the
wonderful thing is that you can get a
job with a multinational corporation
without ever leaving home because we can
all work remotely and be part of
large organizations so
the the names I showed earlier about PWC
Accenture
we're pro
um
you can see that their multinational
corporations operate in many different
companies some are based in India some
are based abroad
and all of them are recruiting
cyber Security Professionals in India
um
do you need programming language
expertise how much of a programming
background should people have will
succeed here
um
you know if you're going to specialize
uh in application security then you're
going to want to spend more time uh you
know encoding in software development
courses
but you have to and what this program
does that's the way it's been aligned is
you learn what you need to learn for the
majority of the cyber security rules and
then you know and a lot of times you
know if you're especially if you're
changing into cyber security if if this
is a change for you you're gonna you're
uh sometimes they'll put you at a lower
level job but then once you're in that
lower level job they'll have all sorts
of training Avenues and you'll find out
where to specialize before you spend all
the time specializing like if you say oh
I know roster I know python or I know go
or typescript what if they don't use
that and so it's always good to to get
the the good base established
um and then when you find an
organization that you're working for
then you find out what they want you to
know yeah I think Python's a safe bet
and yes we talk about python
um uh because it's it's in the Kali
Linux and it's in the red team exercises
so there's and a little bit in the blue
team also because scripting makes your
life as a Defender easier
it's not necessarily that you come in
with the
Advanced skills in Python Programming
because you will be trained along the
way what you know but you do need to
understand the principles of
how programs and algorithms that type of
thing work
um curations program is six months of
course
um
interesting question uh what's the
difference between iits and triple its
and my understanding the iits Indian
Institutes of Technology were founded
starting in the 19th century
uh there are quite a number of them they
began with things like mechanical
engineering moved on to electrical
engineering uh all the different types
of technology and more recently many of
them are in
even management Sciences as well as
Computer Sciences and information
technology whereas the triple it
Bangalore was founded specifically to
address the emerging field
of Information Technology so it has a
more detailed Focus narrow Focus
um
what is the difference between
cyber security expert program the
advanced one presenting so you would
want to look at the different
syllabus
document to look at the different
lists of courses and emphasis
studying electronic engineering you can
it
May well be a good move to Pivot or add
to your skill set cyber security because
both in electronic engineering and in
electrical engineering
you have
many emerging cyber threats uh you're in
electronic engineering you're looking at
the
digital systems for example
um that's obviously a cyber threat
area but if you're looking at the power
engineering for example and utilities
that's a huge problem of infrastructure
protection so
now I like um electronic engineering the
internet of things all the mobile
technologies and then you you more for
merge you put on top of that the cyber
security because that that actually is
one of the biggest vulnerabilities that
we see is someone created a great widget
but security was job number 53.
and we have a Gunder who said some 17
interested in cyber security
where would somebody like that start
um well okay so and I think I see the
same message a few times sort of
um
so if you're 17
um then you know I'm trying to think
that you know have you have you passed
the 12th grade or you know 12th grade
grade 12.
um and
um you know the a program like this
um we do ask that you have that uh that
that college or university experience
um they're simply learned has other
certification courses that you could
take which would be standalone uh you
know and uh or if you think hey I'm
already in University and you know I I
think I'm I'm I I want to get into uh
you know so I don't know what what level
this person is at
um because there are some 17 year olds
who are you know advanced in their
degree program so I don't want to be I
don't want to be too General there you
don't want to make a necessarily make
that assumption that the most recent
hire for uh
SpaceX
Elon musk's company is a 14 year old
programmer who just finished his degree
so
yeah so I mean it's you know the key
thing is if you finish your degree
um you know either finish the degree or
be very close to finishing your degree
right
um one of those every time I find
yourself and I'll see someone that says
oh well I'm completing it within the
next two or three months oh well okay
yes this makes sense to look at because
basically by the time you pick a cohort
you'll be finished your degree
um yeah otherwise you know if you know
if you're not uh in University yet you
can look at some certifications that are
out there maybe you look at that Google
Cloud certification
um I I tend to like the CompTIA
certifications a lot for entry level
roles
um you know get some experience maybe
your employer will reimburse you
um to for your university studies and
then you can come back to a program like
this
so with that let's go on and finish out
our
program
today
for those of you who are interested in
joining this program do you need us to
reach out to you at this point directly
and if if so
answer yes to this question
just coming up in the poll here
and we'll contact you one of our lending
Consultants who will reach out to you
this open for a bit
that's five four three
two one
and
about two-thirds of the people
responding said that they're interested
in having someone reach out so we will
do that
and I want to put into the chat right
now uh for you
the
email address one last time but also the
URL for our
program page so you can take a look
see some of the other information about
the program
got some of those details and you'll
also through that page be able to
contact us
context or learning Consultants
but that's in the chat for everyone
that I want to
say thank you
and the QR code will also take you to
our program page
ask us at symphony.net if you want to
type that in but that's also in the chat
and I want to thank Bill Daly for being
so very generous with this time and
knowledge today really appreciate it
bill
well thank you Stuart pleasure as always
and I want to thank everyone who joined
us from India and other parts of the
globe and we hope that we can welcome
you into the Learning Community with
triple it Bangalore and simply learn
with that we're concluding our webinar
for today
thank you so much
foreign